[Music]
sometimes leaders have difficulty having
tough conversations with other leaders
on their team or executives because
they're worried about you know you
possibly address in a conflict or maybe
it can lead to conflict and so those
difficult conversations don't end up
happening on a team and if you don't do
that if a team doesn't do that there's
no way in the world you can be a great
team you can be a good team but to have
a great team
you gotta address those difficulties you
gotta address those conflicts and the
area I'm talking about with you here
today is about health fitness diet
because when you go into that area
automatically everybody checks their gut
you know everybody says oh my gosh is he
talking about the fact that I'm fat have
I gained some weight do I not look good
and then their defensive are you talking
about me and then there's internal
conflict then people don't want to
communicate with you and they hold on to
the stuff but there's a way of doing
this and I just had it this last week
two weeks who got sat down with my
executives for 25 hours had 29 points
that are covered with the home office
executive this is not sales leaders and
I went all the way down covered every
single point and all the way down at the
bottom for me was you all need to
present to us a personal development
plan on what keywords and what areas you
personally are committing to improving
and I need to have a health plan on what
you're doing to improve your health son
I keep the Semana at the home office we
invest a lot of money into a gym all
these other things and we're planning on
doing some stuff to measure contests on
who has the most steps they take and all
these bonuses we're gonna do on people
staying in shape because the higher the
energy is the more conducive we are
working together in this episode I will
cover with you ten reasons why
exercising will help you make more money
and prior to me getting into the episode
if you got any questions thoughts
comment comment below and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel click on the
subscribe button right here and join a
notification squad right next to it so
point number one what happens when you
exercise your mind becomes sharper just
think about it this way when you come to
work and you haven't exercised you're
lethargic sometimes it takes an hour or
two before you even get into the flow of
doing things right when you exercise
prior to coming to work your mind is
sharper right off to better you just
kind of want to get into it you're in a
flow of things you're going you're
moving you
coming up with better ideas better ways
of you know having this thing advanced
to the next level what if we do this
what if we do that what if we do this
everything does better because your mind
is sharper point number two which is an
extension of point number one
problem-solving you become a better
problem solver problem solving requires
point number three which is energy if
you don't have energy you can't solve
problems why because so think about it
this way if you're in a room in a
boardroom everybody's going back and
forth trying to solve problems and you
see everybody do this one signal let me
tell what the signal is this is the
signal you ready this is the signal of
somebody saying we should just figure
something out and leave the boardroom
this is how it looks like you know what
the signal is what is a signal I want to
go home right this signals I want to
finish this meeting here we should
already wrap up you could have been
seven minutes away from solving this
problem in a way so effective that would
have helped you take your business to
the next level but you were so tired
because you're lethargic from not
exercising not having proper diet now
you just made a good decision instead of
the best decision so you don't advance
to the next level I'm by the way this
happens in sports this happens in
business
this happens in everything you watch
because you can tell when decisions are
made and this is what happens the person
goes like this ah let's just do it
that's not the best decisions that's
just a decision it's not the best
decision the best decision is if we do
this and does this if we do this and
does this if we do this and does this
here let's write the center that that
that you know what I think this is the
best decision we're moving with this
what do you guys think great let's move
forward right because you need energy
point number four you have better sex in
life now what do you mean by better sex
in life why is this so critical I hate
to say it's you you know when you do
better in bed and you're having a better
sex life you just feel better I know
this sounds crazy for some people but
it's a part of it you come to work and
you had a good session in the morning
you feel like a freakin rock star right
or you come to work you had a good night
the night before you know things were
pretty exciting there's a lot of noise
being made some you know intensity vibe
you know things are happening there
things are getting heated the windows
getting foggy you know you kind of come
to work with a little pep in your step
you know your shoulders are back your
chin is up you're like you have no idea
who you're in business with people you
got a rock star in the house better sex
life believe me you will feel better
when the light
are on you don't have to say honey can
we turn the lights off please you want
to turn the lights up because you're not
exercise you don't mind leaving the
lights on if you're exercise and I know
this stinks but it's the reality part of
things that we don't like to talk about
point / 5
let's jealousy and envy why we become
jealous and envious of other people
because other people may be taking care
of their lives their shape their bodies
and we're not and we're saying well you
know while what about with this guy well
what are you so worried about this guy
why are you jealous of this guy you know
you who is the skull he cares about is
his body and all she cares about is her
body so why don't you take care of your
body and why don't you have better that
and why don't you stop eating junk food
and why don't you drink some more water
why don't you have some guy yeah you
know but life is not all about being in
shape you know all this other stuff when
you age your body does this and it's
because of my age and it's because of
this I'm sorry but I've met 70 year olds
that are in better shape than 25 year
olds I met people that are in shape at
70 75 years old so when you exercise and
you're comfortable in your body I'm not
telling you to go out there and look
like some of these models it's not the
point but I'm telling you when you work
out and your energy is good you know you
don't have a lot to be envious and
jealous jealous about because you know
that you're putting the time in yourself
to stay in shape or number six better
memory when you have better memory you
have better relationships you know why
because people like it when you remember
things people like you remember their
names people like you when you remember
conversations people like it when you
remember something that happened two
years ago six years ago
wow he remembers this this is kind of
cool and by the way memory also happens
benefits your negotiation memory helps
you when you're selling memory helps you
when you're doing follow-up memory helps
you when you run into a customer at a
networking him and say Larry good seeing
you I remember how's your family doing
your wife was going through some stuff
because she was running the marathon at
that time right how does she do with the
marathon you remember oh great all of
these things help because you have a
sharper memory point over seven stress
relief you have a lot of stress if you
perform if you're an executive you're a
leader if you're running a gun you're
going after that I got a call earlier
today somebody told me to say Pat how's
everything with you this is an old
friend from high school I'm talking two
years ago 17 18 years old we used to
cause havoc in LA he called me says hey
man you know I'm just seeing you
everywhere
how are you feeling about all this hard
work you know aren't you under stress
yeah you know the higher the decisions
you make the person that's got the most
stress in their lives right now is a guy
that's called the president United
States that guy's got stress okay cuz
anything he does
50 million publications about him that
he's the worst person of all time that
stress what we do is we're running a
business we have family this is not big
stuff there's got to be a release and
exercise and helps you have a release of
that stress you sleep better which is
the next point sleeping better helps you
perform better meaning when you go home
at night how do you sleep do you ever
complain about the fact that you know I
just I don't know why I have a hard time
sleeping that night I've just don't
sleep very good at night I wake up two
or three four different times well guess
what have you ever gone home because you
had such a crazy hard working day that
you would have slept in your car like
have you ever fallen asleep in your car
going home why is that you work your
tail off right when you get home so what
if you exercise you really gave
everything that day you go home you
spend a little bit of time with your
kids your family whatever you're doing
and then you hit the sack
two minutes you're gone well you sleep
better why do you sleep better you're
heavier you sleep heavier you're deeper
thoughts why because you worked out that
then your body needs the rest of your
body says I've worked out today I have
worked today guess what time it is Pat
more time we need to sleep shut it down
boom you go to sleep right so you sleep
better when you exercise point number
nine longevity you last longer in
business which means your value in the
marketplace is higher let me explain to
you what I mean by this this has got
nothing to do with your age I see 27
year olds that are 300 pounds 510 that
will have a shorter life span of
effectiveness in the corporate world or
business then I see a guy that's 53
years old who runs 20 miles every week
he is 510 160 pounds that person's
longevity in business is higher than the
27 year old because the 27 year olds
walking are like this
and that is not good for your health and
it's not good for valuation of your
lifetime of the amount of money you're
going to be making so we got to figure
out a way to have your longevity and a
life be higher and believe me this is
not an easy conversation to have with
anybody some of you are watching this
run I probably lost a lot of viewers in
today's episode but if you're still here
with us guess what more power to you for
having the courage to listen to these
types of difficult conversations that
none of us want to have believe me last
year year and a half ago I was so casual
my body I went to 257 pounds
I dropped 27 pounds and I kept it I
stayed at 230 because that's my body
weight for for being six for longevity
your value goes higher the longer you
can last point number ten you become
more attractive now what do I mean by
more attractive sometimes me more
attractive as smiling you know it's
amazing so a guy can go from looking
like a five to a seven the moment he
smiles right you got a smile on your
face you're just more attractive and you
smile more the more you exercise because
your body's moving you feel better right
so and become more attractive people
want to be around more attractive people
people want to do business with more
attractive people people want to refer
more attractive people you become
attractive it helps in your business and
all of this here that we talked about
the ten points helps you make more money
and helps you advance in life to the
next level whatever that may be for you
and now keep this in mind I have a PDF
for you I want you to download if you
click below here and the PDF for you
it's a score for you to put on every
single one of these things and ask
yourself how amazing is your current sex
life if you haven't if you're watching
13 years on your year you're asking
about sex life you shouldn't be having a
sex life right now take your time I'm
here stop if you're an adult how amazing
is that you may be 32 years old marry
gasket from yourself how do you feel
when you go to it do you feel attractive
do you have a little bit of jealousy and
envy are you being sharper do you make
this just a decent decision or the best
decision score yourself and find out on
the bottom what your score is going to
be between zero to 100
whatever that scores it'll tell you
exactly what things you need to be doing
next to take your game to the next level
look I want to hear from you send me a
tweet at Patrick mid David after
watching this and tell me what's the
take away you got from this video and
what new commitments you are making for
your health in your life with that being
said if you haven't subscribed to the
channel click on the subscribe button
right below take everybody bye-bye